auf und bediene präsentiert von der
leyen verlängert oder weniger lang weg
sind
[Musik]
vom berner oberland in den spanischen
süden miriam thomann und hospiz sie
erfüllen sich den traum vom leben auf
einer pferde finca
auf einer großen farm im westen kanadas
will familie ruckstuhl endlich ihr glück
finden
mit vier tigern sagt remo müller das
abenteuer erwandert zu seiner freundin
alexandra teetz nach deutschland aus sie
bauen einen tierpark
[Musik]
tipp sie da blieben
große
halb verhungert war das kälbchen als
familie ruckstuhl es in obhut nahm jetzt
geht es ihm schon viel besser
noch wittert alexandra das kälbchen mit
milchpulver
zum ersten kälbchen sind noch zwei
weitere dazugekommen
auch ihre mütter konnten ihnen keine
milch geben
ruckstuhl übernahmen die tiere von der
farm für die ehemann markus arbeitet
nun wünscht sich alexandra eine quote
den kälbern frische milch gibt eine
sogenannte armen co
[Musik]
in der letzten folge hatte tochter
josephine ihre erste untersuchung in
einem kanadischen spital der arzt war
zufrieden
zum glück gibt es keine herzprobleme und
markus war beim traditionellen branding
dabei
bei miriams ankunft in spanien gab es
einen ersten konflikt mit ruby
eine karte hano stute ist das erste tier
das us verkaufen möchte
trotz der bauarbeiten im park alexandra
setzte das tier training fort
[Musik]
remo sieger betraten zum ersten mal die
arena problemlos nur rausgehen das nicht
[Musik]
in kanada hat sich die familie ruckstuhl
erneut eingerichtet zum zweiten mal
ihren ersten versuch hatten sie vor gut
eineinhalb jahren wegen der krankheit
ihrer tochter abbrechen müssen
[Gelächter]
josef in cham mit einer seltenen
stoffwechselkrankheit zur welt
ohne eine stammzellentransplantation
hätte die kleine keine chance auf ein
einigermaßen normales leben gehabt
der held ist der unbekannte
stammzellenspender
einhält den die familie nie kennenlernen
wird ein unbekannter der das leben der
familie ruckstuhl aber für immer reicher
gemacht hat
[Musik]
das geschenk sei jetzt ist das ganze
lager man jeden tag
[Gelächter]
hat
der weiß gar nicht wann er es gemacht
hat sie hoffe aber
erst als alexandra und markus sahen das
ist josephine nach der transplantation
von tag zu tag besser ging nahmen sie
einen zweiten anlauf für ihr keiner da
abenteuer
vater markus zimmer in seiner freizeit
einen hühnerstall sein chef stellt ihm
seine werkstatt zur verfügung
[Musik]
kurt fischer ja im youtube-video hat ein
hohes lied in den hot rod
show
noch fehlt ihnen die armen kohl für
seine kälber
wann darf ich vorbeikomme wann kann ich
sie anschauen
sagen wir 11 uhr 30 ist das okay
einfach die hand zusammenleben der
völker
jeder tag morgen fangen
[Musik]
mutig sind sie gelehrig und sensibel die
andalusischen pferde auf der fähre finca
los angeles empfängt der gestütschef
rohrspatz lied zum ersten mal eine
mögliche käuferin
us-pass lee hat in seinem leben schon
vieles gemacht doch als pferdehändler
ist dennoch anfänger
die sechsjährige studie luna ist eines
der pferde für welches sich die
pferdeliebhaberin interessiert
vanessa volkmann besitzt in der nähe
einen eigenen hof
schon vor über einem jahr interessierte
sie sich für die pferde von los angeles
damals war ostern noch nicht besitzer
der tiere
[Musik]
robert der geschäftspartner von us hat
mehr erfahrung
jetzt kommt wieder meine liste zum zug
ja sagt mir
wir haben das zu sagen besprochen robin
dich und wenn du die luna alleine
einnehmen möchtest du nimmst sagen wir
verhandlungs preis 7.000
dann
wenn du die
noch interesse hat dass die die presse
wieder wurden wir sagen 2000 beide
zusammen also ich hab
die sag ich doch so
der fälle macht ist komplett das ist so
moment ja
da kommt wieder das kommt die
1000 zusammenkommen
und weil das sage ich ganz ehrlich man
sonst ist das für mich ein defizit es
bleibt hart und dies obwohl
kaufinteressenten nicht gerade schlange
stehen
[Musik]
uns bleibt keine zeit um über den
gescheiterten handeln nachzudenken
er hilft seine freundin miriam die
pferde für den nächsten ausritt der
reitschüler zusammenzutreiben
merian soll heute zum ersten mal eine
reitgruppe in der freien natur anführen
[Musik]
oder gibt es vielleicht
hab ich mir
langsam geht sind sich auch die
großkatze rani an die neue tiger arena
mit allem
aber alle werden langsam sowie heimisch
[Musik]
im tunnel oder was
ja ich glaube
dass man trainiert
minute
als segen sie irgendwie verunsichert
oder so trainieren dass heißt remo will
mit seinen sibirischen tigern zusammen
in die arena steigen
doch zuerst schaut er sich einen hand
same rheinpark zuwachs an
so unglaublich herzlich oder
das ist ne lima oder
die mini schweinchen gehören neu auch
zum tierpark alexandra will sich um die
kleinen kümmern und sie trainieren
[Musik]
ja mein allererstes haustier waren und
wenn jetzt jeden tag haben dann hast es
ja ganz gut und schweine sind sehr sehr
intelligent und ich bin jetzt auch mal
ganz gespannt einfach die die
schweinchen zu trainieren und auch noch
mit den hunden ein bisschen zu
vergleichen und zu mal
so ich mache ich gar nichts wenn ganz
gibt zu ich
jetzt lassen sie erstmal in ruhe
erstmal ankommt und weiter
[Musik]
beef land so nennt sich das land im
süden alberta wo sich markus ruckstuhl
mit seiner familie niedergelassen hat
die gegend ist bekannt für saftige
steaks aber weniger für milchprodukte
dem score ist eine der wenigen fahrer in
der gegend der milchwirtschaft betreibt
[Musik]
die dort hinten die schwarze
die rote und die ganz hinten
wie alt sind sie beide sind fünfjährige
farmers korea zwei kühe zu verkaufen
die kur die markus sucht soll viel milch
geben denn die ruck sturms haben drei
kälber zu versorgen diese nur mit
milchpulver aufzuziehen ist viel zu
teuer
wieviel willst du für sie haben 2008
rund
2800 das ist viel geld
[Musik]
jetzt denkt sagen die zwei ja vielleicht
2 200
[Musik]
ein foto für alexandra denn sie bestimmt
beim kauf mit
[Musik]
so was macht ihr mit der milch wir haben
drei weisen kälbchen und wir brauchen
natürlich auch für uns selber
macht joghurt und käse joghurt bestimmt
vielleicht auch
wir sind er seit kurzem ihr etwa seit
einem monat
dann werde ich mal mit meiner frau
sprechen und dann anrufen
ja
[Musik]
remo ist wieder einmal am ausmessen und
bauen
22 huskies brauchen auch ein neues
zuhause
700 quadratmeter groß soll das gehege
werden
und das geht oder
wie kannst du ich habe wohl überraschen
aber zu zweit
ich muss weiter machen
aber
[Musik]
geht der ist auch nicht ganz gut aber
ich komme
aus der schweiz sind heidi und jörg
angereist remus eltern
fertig gebaut haben die beiden das tiger
haus noch nie gesehen
[Musik]
jetzt spielen wir schon
[Gelächter]
schon lange erwachsen doch die
bestätigung der eltern tut gut und deren
handfeste unterstützung kann er erst
recht gebrauchen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja und
ich hoffe nicht sehr schön russland und
usa und der schweiz und dann ins
kleinste und ein hands langweilige freut
aber ich glaube jetzt ist so
markus merk enthält es
funktioniert das kann kein händler
[Musik]
sind wir meistens
wenn screen hält das funktioniert dann
sind wieder foto pi sind ja auch
urlauber jetzt dass ich gut
[Musik]
mit wallach max soll miriam heute zum
ersten mal eine gruppe reitschüler auf
dem freien gelände anführen
[Musik]
team kollegin barbara unterstützt merian
sie zeigt ihr die reitpferde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aber normal ist niedrig
fährt spitze auf
[Musik]
ist ein neuling am berg ist robert nicht
weit
[Musik]
bei verlängern
der ausritt ist gelungen das wird
gebührend gefeiert
mit der passenden musik natürlich
[Musik]
und für einmal scheint auch robert
entspannt zu sein
auf der zukunft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ruckstuhl halten familien hat ab und
besprechen den puck auf
jetzt
24 jährig bei der domenicali brett
nach der
wahl sicher womit dringlichkeit
entschädigung 15 liter am tag gehen
angst dass das skript geht sie sich
nicht nur für die kälber auch für die
kinder josephine und elena soll die
milch reichen die familie will sich so
weit wie möglich selbst versorgen das
ist nicht unbedingt günstiger aber
gesünder
mit dem ersparten gehen die eltern
sorgfältig um sie planen langfristig
[Musik]
nicht darum mehr geld usa hoffen dass es
lange
zeit
das letzte
so ist auch dass hühner häuschen eine
investition in die zukunft
[Musik]
die perfekte kombination schweizer
qualität und kanadisches holz
auf markus chef don lauro interessiert
sich für den stall
ich hoffe dass keine anderen hühner
dieses haus sehen wir werden danach echt
[Musik]
den kreis dieses hauses könnte den
einige eier kaufen
[Musik]
wow
eine show im traditionellen gewand der
beste reiter auf los angeles zeigt den
radkästen sein können und dass der
andalusischen pferde
langsam zwar aber stetig die beziehung
zwischen miriam und robert entspannt
sich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schon als kind ist miriam geräten
seither trägt sie den traum mit pferden
zu arbeiten in ihrem herzen nun kann sie
ihre erfahrung weitergeben
[Musik]
und wenn wirklich wahrscheinlich gezählt
tief sitze und ganz wenig
[Musik]
und dann verschieben
alles was ich mit drauf machen
fußball stehen den war bisher galoppiert
[Musik]
nur mit 1770 rückzieher
gates abstiege
gemacht wird
miriams wissen ihr umgang mit pferden
und gästen beeindruckt auch robert
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
aber wirklich
sieht aus wie damals jetzt ist es
wunderschön so
aber so sieht wirklich gut aus
[Musik]
heute will remo zum ersten mal mit
seinen tigern in die neue arena steigen
zwei wochen bleiben ihm und den tigern
bis zur eröffnung
sein künftiger schwiegervater peter
unterstützt ihn dabei er lässt die tiger
rein und raus
nicht von außen schließen
[Musik]
eine physische betriebe man muss einfach
htc smart ist womöglich bewusst ihnen
gott die bretter holen
muss man einfach konzentriert hier
gut dann machen wir
[Musik]
die ganze denen schon öffnen
die eltern stellen sich als test
publikum zur verfügung
mir ist sehr häufig der begriff ist
vorletzter
das mädchen brach
ok
platz
ich komme hier hinke hinterher
hinke hinterher
gravogl sitz
richtig sitzt girlie gratis
ok ich muss das mädchen
und läufer vom
nur eine mark das spektakel nicht mit
ansehen
alexandra held es fast nicht aus wenn
ihr liebster mit den tigern in der arena
steht
[Musik]
klar zu ziehen langsam
angst ganz ganz schlecht und wenn du
angst herrsche und zog bis mich machen
und immer machine co dann bist du die
auch komisch also glaubt seid ihr nicht
noch stress
also mir ist eigentlich wohl wenn ich
irgendwie und jetzt ja über 50
vorstellungen gemacht dass verschiedene
trainings und da wird man mit der zeit
auch ruhige und macht einfach ganz in
ruhe
[Musik]
also viel bessere denkt jetzt im
nachhinein natürlich schon interessiert
ist
[Musik]
für die eltern ruckstuhl war es ein
herzenswunsch dass ihre kinder direkt
vor der haustüre spielen trennen viel
bewegung ist auch das beste für josef
ins entwickeln
[Musik]
mutter alexandra feiert heute ihren 31
geburtstag sie hat freunde und nachbarn
eingeladen
markus wartet mit einem geschenk der
praktischen sorte auf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wer das dafür
und ich schaue nie was sie kaufen
das geburtstagsfest ist auch ein
wiedersehen mit nachbarn und freunden
die sie bereits bei ihrem ersten kurzen
aufenthalt in kanada kennengelernt haben
[Musik]
alexandra hat hamburger gemacht
selbstverständlich mit fleisch aus der
region
die vorbesitzerin persönlich bringt den
geburtstagskuchen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein schöner geburtstag neigt sich
langsam dem ende zu
alexandra ist zufrieden und hat nur
einen wunsch
und lebt oder so so gesund wie ethisch
dass
die lena natürlich gesund bleibt
das ist mein geburtstag
[Musik]
völlig ungezwungen nicht mal
fast geschafft drei tage vor eröffnung
tollen die 22 huskies in ihrem nägel
nagelneuen gehege herum
wieder zu sehen
doch damit ist die arbeit noch nicht
getan
sie fühlen sich extrem wohl
ruhig ein spaß 13 uhr springen glaubten
an jedem rad auf dem platz kam aber
schlage das dach drauf
das ist noch
[Musik]
das vergessen das gab uns heute am 10
niemand gefunden
wir haben wir denn morgen wie heute
heute in szene
ja das ihn vergessen der stall für die
fluten also morgen ohne den anhänger
oder was ja die brauchen dringend ihren
stall ich gerade mal gucken ob ich die
telefonnummer finde
ja schönen tag hier ist alexander tietz
von der villa tc wr
okay
okay ich kläre das ab und melde mich hin
kommen noch mal ist es in ordnung ja
danke
morgen donnerstag dass niemand da heute
bis 17 uhr
weißt du was ich fahre jetzt einfach los
und hole das mit dem fördern hänger up
all der stress und mitten im
schlussspurt zieht ein mächtiges
sturmtief heran
seit bald sechs monaten lebt muss auf
los angeles jetzt steht der große
vertrauensbeweis an
oster stift wird zum meister zumindest
temporär
robert geht zum ersten mal seit zehn
jahren in die ferien nun soll uns
übernehmen
svensk nein das ist ein foul ich vermute
dass das
große sport als heute aber lasst sie
nicht rufen hey wie mach
kaputt
also ich
mit dem riesen gut der quiz das ich mir
wichtig dass doch
ein fehler
und du wirst
das ist so
[Musik]
ab
man kann das krank
robert liegt mit seiner freundin vor
drei wochen nach costa rica
[Musik]
so
kein wind sondern orkanartige böen haben
den tierpark in bel fest im griff eine
schwere sturm gehört das dach vom großen
schuppen aufgerissen
warum
x3cc dem ding stand kalt und genau jetzt
wir müssen die vordere ecke dann gleich
auch noch da fängt auch schon ab da ist
der nagel schon draußen
wer noch nicht
nein das alles macht den abschluss macht
das know how zu beruhigen
jetzt kurz vor oder
student
[Musik]
kein ziegenstall ein defektes dach und
das drei tage vor eröffnung
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
ist am vorabend der park eröffnung das
ziegengehege noch immer nicht fertig
[Musik]
baldauf zukauf kanadisch markus
ruckstuhl treibt die kinder auf die
sommerweide
am ziel gibt es das traditionelle
pferderennen und
die ruckstuhl haben endlich eine kuh
[Musik]
auf der spanischen finca passiert
schlimmes kurz nach robert abreise
stirbt ein pferd
wie wollen merian und es damit umgehen
sondern sie robert die hiobsbotschaft in
die ferien übermitteln
[Musik]
kubilay türkyilmaz
neuen star
[Musik]
uff und tvs präsentiert wurde der leyen
für oliver längert oder weniger lang weg
sind